the Joe Rogan experience I remember the
first one I ever saw as a kid was the
shining and that's still that's a
interesting one right because Stephen
King didn't like it yeah that makes
sense because it is wildly different
from it it's a it's a huge departure
from the novel so I can imagine if
you're an artist and then someone takes
your artwork and they completely change
it in many different ways
they both you know they changed it a
bunch of ways but they kept it a bunch
of ways too
it became like a collaboration between
him and Kubrick because it was clearly
his original idea but yeah he wanted I
believe Stephen King wanted that
character to go crazy he didn't wanted
to have this [ __ ] edge like rifle
like Jack Nicholson had an edge like
right from the beginning and then became
insane and then you know yeah I know
what it's like yet to be an alcoholic
who just stopped drinking and and I
think you have that edge almost from the
get-go yeah a little bit but I mean
Jack's jack that movie was so good it
was top top 10 all-time favorites what's
crazy it's like someone needed to tell
Stephen King like I know it was so good
holy [ __ ] that's a good movie so many
great moments I loved and back then when
it came out like people don't understand
like The Shining is like what is that
82 or 1980 I think cuz it thinks so
yeah so 1980 people you've got to
understand what we're talking about a
whole different world you know there's
no there's no special effects if there
are they're they're not very good
they're all like yeah and Empire Strikes
Back yeah
it's clunky yeah the special effects are
clunky I guess Empire Strikes Back is
pretty [ __ ] dope and then a lien was
79 that's right all right but that's
falling apart
Blade Runner was 82 so there's really
not much else though but there is a lot
of clunky so they did this movie with
just just that mean just all that this
yeah all the
different crazy moments like that
bathroom moment with that mass coming
through the door there's so many of
those moments the moment with the old
lady
cuz Kubrick was a [ __ ] master at
creating suspense and and using the sets
and the color contrasts like just the
the the the color patterns are
unsettling and the fact that he used
those twins weren't exactly they weren't
twins there are just little differences
that makes it unsettling there's so many
different ways do you know he used to do
complex mathematics for fun that's how
what a genius he was a trippy dude even
by far I think the greatest director of
all time well he definitely is one of
them and one of the most unique ones I
said you know there's a crazy conspiracy
theory connected to the shining in the
moon land it's all about the number on
the door is the exact same amount of
thousands of miles 237 and it's two
hundred thirty seven thousand miles away
it varies see that's the problem with
that argument is it like the the
distance between the earth and the moon
is not constant I think it moves a
little bit so I think it goes as far as
two hundred sixty five thousand feet out
if I'm just from or miles round rather
265 thousand miles out and it goes to
237 I think it very think it goes like
this I think it has like an elliptical
orbit around the earth a little bit I
think I made that up is that true yeah
it sounds like her so I was in the
middle of reading the 2:37 stuff yeah I
heard it was also possibly about Native
Americans how the hotel is built on an
ancient Indian burial ground and even
Shelley Duvall sort of looked Native
American here Native American music
playing in the opening credits I
wouldn't be surprised there was many
layers to it yeah he's just brilliant he
was a brilliant brilliant the little kid
did have an Apollo 11 sweater yeah sure
he did have an Apollo 11 that's pretty
not a nose I just remember in the back
room in the stock room there was like a
can of a product with a giant it was
like Geronimo's head on the on the
I'm sure there's so much that there's
probably many layers the Kubrick is not
gonna operate on one layer no he's
probably gonna have a weird [ __ ] in
there I mean look at 2001
what a mind oh my god what a mind [ __ ]
yeah well there's so much of his work
you know and he's the guy that the the
conspiracy theorists when they get the
the most crazy when they when they
really want to dive into who did it they
think it was all Kubrick the Kubrick
literally filmed the fake moon land
right right bloated it to the American
TV satellite if anyone could do it it'd
be him he'd be the guy again to do it
you imagine that was that was really
what happen I'm for all these years
I remember hearing all [ __ ]
conspiracy theorists about the
Illuminati killing him because he made a
yeah well they were worried he was gonna
open his [ __ ] mouth oh no to those
his last one like enough this guy's
getting too close because I think he
died like a like a week after that movie
course he did that's [ __ ] that's how
they roll
[Applause]